[Applause]
[Music]
crystal clear waters and the speeches
and passable jungles landscapes that
take us to the very heart of what the
word paradise means my friends this is
the Philippines a remote and
little-known country that has
nevertheless had a significant
historical connection with both Spain
and somehow with many of Latin America's
Hispanic countries as well this former
Spanish colony in Southeast Asia was for
more than three centuries parts of the
Spanish Empire then after the defeat of
Spanish troops in 1898 by those of the
United States the Philippines were sold
to the u.s. for twenty million dollars
with adjustments for inflation that
works out to about six hundred and
twenty million dollars in today's money
yes at that time the colonies we're sold
as if they were plots of beachfront land
of course in this case the sale and
price were practically determined by the
United States after all they had just
won the war and they had the biggest
guns
of course far from gaining independence
are at least improving its independence
with the United States leading the way
freedom for Filipinos ironically did not
come after being sold to the Americans
the Philippines was governed by the u.s.
for nearly five decades until finally in
1946 that gained their actual
independence since then the trajectory
of this country has not exactly been a
bed of roses
but rather it's been a bunch of thorns
dictatorships corruption violence drug
trafficking Islamism the Philippines
manages to bring together a bit of all
of the worst problems that lurk in
countries as far away as Venezuela
Honduras and Pakistan and the combat
less know they have detective Rodrigo
Duterte
is currently the Philippine president
and despite being democratically elected
let's just say there's little to no sign
of democracy in fact is pretty much the
opposite
check out philippine mayor undo turner
co-list shot dead the straits times a
slaughter them policy that targets the
philippines poor al jazeera president
rodrigo duterte or on drugs policy has
led to more than 20,000 deaths since
2016 okay so we are talking about
full-blown extrajudicial executions in
fact the Philippine government has
actually legalized them
[Music]
so do you want to know more about this
faraway country do you want to know more
about the dark figure of Rodrigo Duterte
so if you do and why wouldn't you listen
up the Philippines a country of the best
and worst first off this is about to get
pretty heavy so I think to start off
with it would be a good idea to get to
know the country we're talking about a
little better and I have to tell you
that we're talking about a very unusual
country on one hand we're talking about
the first country in all of Asia to have
a constitution approved by a partially
elected to Congress so a good thing that
happened all the way back in the late
19th century in the short period between
the end of Spanish rule and the u.s.
invasion there was a short-lived
unrecognized Republic known
internationally as the Republic of
mallows
but of course after paying twenty
million dollars for these islands the
Americans were very clear that this
territory belonged to them so they had
no qualms about using all the force
necessary to end the self-proclaimed
Republic in the sort of ironic twist
that only history can give us any
support for the independence cause was
considered a criminal activity by the US
and in 1906 American troops arrested and
executed members of the last government
of the Republic including its President
General
Macario it's a cape death will come to
us all sooner or later so I will stand
calmly before the Lord Almighty but I
want to tell you that we are not bandits
or thieves as the Americans have accused
us but members of the revolutionary
force that defended our motherland the
Philippines long live democracy and
hopefully our independence will be
reborn in the future long live the
Philippines
Macario sake so the Philippines is an
extremely diverse country to give you an
idea is 110 million inhabitants speak
170 different languages that is a bigger
mess than my teeth and yet that's not
his biggest problem not by a long shot
despite the fact that up until the
coronavirus crisis this country had gone
20 years without suffering a single
quarter of negative growth and even
though over the last decade the average
economic growth has been almost 6
percent per year the Philippines remains
a very poor country a country where the
majority of the population remains
anchored in absolute poverty this is a
country where the average salary is just
over $200 per month and we're one of the
main sources of wealth is the nearly 30
billion dollars the more than 12 million
Filipinos around the world transfer and
remittances to their families each year
and if we consider the problems that the
government has controlling a country
made up of more than 7,000 islands per
infrastructure and 170 different
languages then we find it is the perfect
breeding ground for the emergence of non
recommended activities so my visual
politics poverty and lack of control by
the government and a legal system over a
large part of the country has made the
Philippines one of the biggest Asian
epicenters for human trafficking and
also for drug trafficking the
Philippines is not only the largest
consumer of meth amphetamines and
marijuana in eastern Asia but also its
largest producer and do you know where
most of the cartels operating in the
country come from they come from China
and you can get an idea of what this
might entail as in other countries where
these mafias exists violence and lack of
security are a huge problem around all
of these narcotic mafias a whole web of
illegal economies have also been created
dedicated to the trafficking of people
organs smuggling of all kinds and
practically any other criminal activity
that you can think of of course going
hand-in-hand with this
corruption is almost institutionalized
as one more economic stream
and as you can probably imagine poverty
has forced many families to have to
throw themselves into the arms of one of
the many underworld groups operating in
the country and it is against this
backdrop as we shall see that the figure
of detecting arises a president
basically characterized by two things a
heavy hand as an a very hard line
against crane and promises of economic
growth for the latter he means to clear
the deck and switch strategic partners
Yesi for many years the Philippines had
been very close to the United States
obviously so much so that Washington has
come to classify its relationship with
the Philippines as special and the
nation is considered one of its most
important strategic allies in Asia along
with countries such as Taiwan South
Korea or Thailand since President Zhu
territories arrival in 2016 the Manila
Washington access has been increasingly
veering to Beijing especially over the
past two years
look and you can see what changed their
husband May 2017
doTERRA says China's see threatened war
if Philippines drills for oil
Reuters April 2018 Philippines president
Rodrigo Duterte says he needs China
quote loves see Jean King CNN I need
China more than anybody else at this
point I need China
I simply love see Jinping he understood
he understands my problem and is willing
to help so I would say thank you China
but Rico do Tareq President of the
Philippines above all else
Duterte wants money investment and as
much Chinese capital as possible to lift
the country's economy he couldn't be
more transparent about it check the
sector our destiny lies in Asia not in
the Middle East as they're too busy
fighting and they don't have any money
and if you don't have money
you're not my friend so I go to China
plenty of money President Deuter are you
kind of surprised at such sincerity
because honestly it probably shouldn't
be Duterte is anything but a normal
president and in a way is quite logical
day should get along better with
dictators like zheng Peng than with the
leaders of Western democracies so what's
the reason well what's not
[Music]
detect the toughest resident
if anything is characterized Rodrigo
Duterte since the beginning of his
presidency is that he is a president who
speaks plainly and who does not mess
around let's just say that if we were
talking about scruples he has absolutely
none he is willing to do whatever it
takes to fight not only drug trafficking
and criminals but also his own political
adversaries in fact his harsh ways of
arrington theme around the world for
being a dictator and a tyrant and for
not respecting even the most basic of
human rights take for example what
happened during the Tsar's Cove to
crisis
Duterte promised to enforce quarantines
completely at any cost
listen up deterrence response to the
coronavirus shoot them dead foreign
policy my orders to the police and
military if there is trouble or the
situation arises where your life is on
the line shoot them dead understand dead
I'll send you to the grave don't test
the government Rodrigo Duterte so two
days after these statements a sexy three
year old farmer was shot by police for
not wearing a mask according to the
agents the man threatened them with a
scythe proportionality what the hell is
that anyway in this environment there
has been an increase in shootings of
civilians by police across the country
something that is not covered up at all
by a law enforcement anyone out at the
wrong time will be shot you sensible
Philippine police officer in a radio
report and that is not all following the
government's own orders and some
municipalities people who are caught
skipping curfews have been locked in dog
cages in other places punishments have
also been applied that could easily be
mistaken for torture of course this kind
of thing doesn't starts with a corona
virus
Duterte is a guy who simply does not
believe in reintegration according to
him as he is expressed many times those
who commit crimes are nothing more than
expendable social waste that is
precisely why Duterte established a zero
tolerance policy against drug
traffickers and narcotics consumers
since his arrival in power he has also
ordered a shoot to kill policy
and look consider this for just one
moment despite all of this being a clear
violation of the most basic human rights
what the Philippines has experienced
tells us that this tough approach is not
the best way to fight crime and what
detente has done is simply to set in
motion a whole machinery of
extrajudicial executions has given the
police many public officials and their
own government the ability to get rid of
people with total impunity and this is
in a country with very high levels of
corruption and despotism
let me ask you a simple question would
you dare in an environment like this
oppose the government or denounced the
Wheeling's and dealings of for example a
corrupt police officer I bet that you
wouldn't you see since the first
zero-tolerance policy was launched or
perhaps we should call that the zero
legality policy at least six thousand
six hundred people are estimated to have
lost their lives in the Philippines
according to the police however that
number according to Human Rights Watch
goes all the way up to twenty-seven
thousand people to top it all off many
of those people had nothing to do with
drug trafficking or mafias or any
criminal activity at all but they were
simply people who were caught in the
crossfire or corruption or for some
other reason
[Music]
so at this point how do you think that
Filipino residents raped their president
well contrary to what you might think
Rodrigo GTA's popularity is around 80
that's right
80 percent it is a little bit less than
complete favor but how on earth can a
guy like that achieve these levels of
approval well it may seem hard to accept
in our culture but an Asian head by
crane narcotics trafficking human
trafficking and poverty it's no wonder
that for many people things like freedom
and human rights are left far in the
background indeed according to polls
only 15 percent of residents consider
democracy to be essential and even for
us in the West some of this might be
starting to sound creepily familiar in
the end what we have already seen happen
many other times happens despair
disappointment and corruption are often
the best ways to feed authoritarian
leaders anyway it's your turn now as a
president like to talk to entitled to
pass on human rights even if he pursues
an end that theoretically could be good
is the fight against crime more
important than law and justice do you
think you would like someone like
detecting in your country before I
safety about the comments this has been
a pretty heavy video so why don't you
give your pet a little pat to give your
mom a hug and get yourself a nice cup of
tea
so that we can all feel better anyway
leave your comments here below and if
you like this video do not forget to
give us a like subscribe to our Channel
and you can keep yourself up to date
with everything is to come by clicking
on a little on button down there thanks
for tuning in we'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
you